prime minister dominic cummins says
you're lying about the may 20th bring
your own booze down in street event
he says you were explicitly warned
personally by him and your private
secretary martin reynolds was also
warned that this was outside the rules
and should be cancelled but you went
ahead anyway
that's been confirmed to me by a second
down and street figure you in contrast
say you had no prior knowledge of this
party
you thought it was a work event
have you lied to the public and to
parliament
no beth but i want to begin by
repeating my apologies to
everybody for the misjudgments that
i've made that we may have made in
number 10 and and beyond
whether in downing street or throughout
the the pandemic and
i i do know how infuriating it must be
for people up and down the country in
view of the the huge sacrifices that
people have have made the way that
they've kept discipline and the way
they've followed the rules followed the
guidance done the right thing to think
that
that didn't happen in in number 10
downing street so i want to
just say to you on on that point uh no
nobody
told me that what we were doing was as
you say uh against the rules uh that the
event in question was
something that we were going to do
something that wasn't a work event
and you know as i said in the house of
commons
when i went out into that garden
i i thought that i was attending
a work event
i think it's very important that
we
see what sue grey see what the inquiry
has to say
i will be coming back to the house of
commons
as soon as it's reported as soon as i as
i can after it's reported and i'll be
i'll be telling people more okay just to
be clear then you're saying that dominic
commons is lying and his version of
events is not true well i'm what i'm i
just repeat i i i deeply sorry for
mistakes
are you saying that he's lying and his
version of it's very important viewers
will want to know the public will want
to know and peace will want to know
he is on the record saying under oath
you are lying that you were warned about
this event and you went ahead anyway
that you knew
i can tell you categorically
categorically that nobody told me and
nobody's nobody said that
this was something that was against the
rules it was a breach of the of the
cobia rules that we were doing something
that wasn't a a work event because
uh
frankly i don't think
uh i can't imagine why on earth it would
have gone ahead or why it would have
been allowed uh to go ahead
my memory of this event as i've said
is going out into the garden for
about 25 minutes what i implicitly
thought was a
a work event
and talking to staff thanking staff
um i i can't remember exactly how many
but for about 25 minutes i was there i
then went back to my uh my office and
continued my work um you know
i i do humbly apologize to people for
misjudgments that were made but that is
the the very very best of my
recollection about this event that's
what i've uh i've said to to the inquiry
we'll have to see what they what they
say dominic lawson wrote in the sunday
times that as well you had been told by
two officials it was a party and should
be cancelled you were dismissive he
writes you said they were overreacting
said martin reynolds was your loyal
labrador is that also untrue
well i i've told you uh and i i repeat
i'm
deeply sorry for misjudgments that that
were made no misjudgments and yes if it
figures ultimately because it seems like
you're trying to pass the blame
no i carry i carry full responsibility
for for what took place
but nobody told me i can absolutely i'm
absolutely categorical as nobody said to
me this is an event that is against the
rules
that is in breach of what we're asking
everybody else to do i should not go
ahead what i remember is going out into
that garden for a short time
and
uh 25 minutes or so
thanking staff who had worked on a
covered who were continuing to work on
kovid
and then going back to my to my office
and
all i can say is you know
in retrospect as i said to the house of
commons beth you know if i had my time
again
uh i would not have allowed things to to
developed in that way and when i went
out into that garden uh yes i i should
probably have told people
uh i should have looked around and said
well we've got to go back indoors or
this isn't the right way
to do things
but
and i i apologize for for that but i i
hope that people will understand the
circumstances we were we were operating
in but
i i've just got to ask people to to wait
for for sue grey to report so can i just
be clear so just so we're really clear
on the record what you're saying about
all of these allegations no one verbally
warned you at any point
and you neither saw
nor was told about any email
from martin reynolds about this bring
your own booze party or that anyone
around you in your office or any
advisers raised this with you you had no
problem categorically that i never saw
the i've seen the email
uh the the martin reynolds the email of
invitation
uh clearly that was not phrased in a in
a way that was right after the event
yeah i only saw the other day and i saw
it uh you know when it when it emerged
um
uh i think it was if you didn't
your closest adviser and he said he
verbally warned you about this is he
like
i can't believe
uh that we would have gone ahead with an
event that
people were saying was against the rules
or against
uh you're not what you're asking people
to do
and nobody warned me that it was against
the rules i can i'm absolutely
categorical because i would i would
remember that okay
so if sue grey uncovers a different
version of events and it merges you did
mislead parliament will you resign
we'll have to see what she says and
uh i i think that she should be given
the space to get on and conclude her
inquiry and i would urge everybody who
has
knowledge of this and understand you
know memories of this to
to tell her what they know so you'd like
her to interview dominic commons
you know it's it's not for me to decide
who she's got to interview but i think
everybody who has memories of these
events
uh should tell her what they know if it
emerges you've misled parliament will
you resign well let's see what the
report says
your chancellor said today that the
ministerial code is clear on these
matters when asked if you should resign
if
you lied to parliament
in principle should a prime minister
stay in office if it emerges that he
misled parliament well i think we need
to see what the report says beth you
know greatest possible respect to
to you and to all our viewers i think we
need to
we you know
we can't anticipate what the conclusion
of this inquiry will be you must be
worried you're going to lose your job
what i'm
thinking about today beth is
coming through the covid pandemic in the
way that we are i'm here at a community
diagnostics hub in in north london
where there are 108 000 people on the
waiting list in the royal free
incredible hospital but they've got a
huge backlog now partly caused as you
know by covid
and what
we got here is a community diagnostics
hub one of 40 that we green lighted in
october we're going up to 100 of them
and i think they will make a big
difference to people
uh on on waiting lists
and i want to see that a couple
i have been asked by the broadcasters to
ask these questions you know i'm here to
represent everybody yeah
uh you're not ruling out that you will
have to resign if you've missed a party
i mean what i'm saying is that we need
to
you've asked me what i'm what i'm
focused on what i want to do what i want
to do no i asked you
if you it's found that sue gray finds
you misled parliament will you resign
that's what i'm asking you you're not
answering well
what i'm saying to to you with the
deepest respect beth is that we've got
to wait for the outcome of the
of the report but in the meantime i'm
focused on
delivering here uh at this
fantastic community diagnostics hub uh
run by people from the from the royal
free but offering an amazing service
what i'm focused on
number one
is clearing the covered backlogs and and
delivering on all our priorities for the
british people
we've we've still got a
a problem with kobe we still got 16 000
people in in beds and since i've got the
you know i'm in front of the cameras i
must remind people it's a great thing to
do to get a boost
we've still got a lot of
people who could get located let me just
try one more time do you accept on
principle that a prime minister if he's
found with misled parliament has to
stand down from office well i'm telling
you beth and i you know i repeat this is
that i i think that you're slightly
anticipating things
i will come back to parliament uh with a
full account and uh when the inquiry
reports but it would be quite wrong of
me
to anticipate uh or prejudge whatever
the inquiry making sure just one more
thing some of your mps that and members
of the public think that this is your
barna castle moment that the idea that
you walked into the garden
there's 40 people there the tables are
laid out with food and drink and there's
alcohol being served
in the middle of a lockdown and you
think that's a work event that is just
ludicrous isn't it you are
just taking the mickey out of the
british people
you know how silly that sounds don't you
i think what people need to do is wait
and see what the the report says but i i
repeat my
my deep apologies to people for mistakes
that
may have been made on my watch but you
see that that looks ridiculous
i i
i repeat my apologies for any
and all
misjudgments that were made uh for which
i take full responsibility but i think
people do need to to wait and see the
the conclusion of the
of the report and i i will i will draw
the necessary uh consequences and
conclusions but then come back to the
highest okay i've got one final thing on
this before we move to kovid this
because this is important this is the
first time we've seen you since reports
emerged
in the daily telegraph not denied by
down street about two boozy parties held
in the garden in the buildings of number
ten the night before prince philip's
funeral when the country was in national
mourning
was having to apologize to the queen
about those parties
the night before she put her husband of
over 70 years she laid him to rest was
that a moment of shame for you i i
deeply and bitterly regret
uh that that that happened and i can
only uh
and renew my apologies both to
uh to her majesty and
uh
to the country
for misjudgments that that were made and
and for which i take full responsibility
do you think you can recover from this
you might be able to survive but can you
recover
your polling is terrible the public
think you should go your mps are in
revolt six of them have publicly said
you should resign
beth i i understand people's feelings
and i understand why people feel as
as strongly as they do about this issue
i i and i i repeat my
apologies for for what happened and i
i i'm heartily heartily sorry for
misjudgments that were made uh in in
number ten so right but
what i what i do need to do uh is is
wait for
the conclusion of the of the inquiry uh
and then
uh but before then to to keep going with
what we're we're doing and i think what
all the people you've described want to
see
is a government that's focused uh
nonetheless on taking the country
forward in the way that we are and don't
forget of what whatever the the the the
stories that you've been
rightly covering uh there is also
another story which is about which i
think you want to come on to uh which is
about a country that has been able to
come out of covid faster than any other
comparator country a country that has a
higher level of vaccination than any
other comparable country a country that
has the most open society an economy
currently now that
uh has been
delivered by this government uh but we
need to get on and do much much more we
need to help people uh with the cost of
living we need to tackle uh issues at uh
at our borders uh we need to we need to
fix the the cover backlogs we need to we
need to rebuild the economy we have a
huge agenda of work and that is what
this government is going to get on and
deliver you must be very worried at the
moment that you are going to be ousted
by your mps that the public will not
forgive you for what has happened in
downing street during those two
lockdowns you must be worried i think
it's very important that
people who do my job
should be focused the whole time
on what we're delivering for the british
public and that's what like so you're
not worried
i'm focused on
what we're doing to
keep rolling out the boosters to move
the economy forward to tackle the cost
of living to make sure we help people
with the cost of their of their fuel
bills uh this winter beth we're doing
everything we can to get our country
through
and and to make sure that we continue to
have a strong economic recovery it's i
think it's an extraordinary thing that
here in the uk we now have 420 000 more
people in employment than there were
before the pandemic began i mean
those are those are the types of issues
on which i must focus yes and i i'm only
asking this because this is what your
mps are telling me that they think you
are going to have to stand down from
office it's not my view
it's their view but i have got one final
question
on kovid has cabinet this morning rubber
stamped the decision not to renew plan b
measures
we've got to be careful about kobe we've
got to continue to
remember that it's a threat and don't
forget there are still 16 000 people in
hospital because of because of covid and
uh
don't if you don't get vaccinated you're
eight times more likely to end up in
hospital
ninety percent of the people in uh in
intensive care are people who have not
been boosted
we need to make sure that people
learn that lesson and get boosted now
and just finally do you think you'll be
prime minister by the end of the year
i'm focused if i may say so beth i know
you want to take it uh back to
to me in my career and all the rest but
i am focused completely on delivering
for the people of this of this country
uh getting us through covid uh we've had
the fastest booster roller of any
european country we've got the most open
economy that's because of the hard work
of everybody in government amazing work
of the nhs all the doctors and nurses up
and down the country and that's that's
who i'm here to support and to thank and
and what we're also doing is rolling out
to boost to bust the backlogs what we're
doing is rolling out the community
diagnostics
hubs and and this is an amazing example
you've got patients who can come in
get screened get scanned get tested fast
and
you cut out a huge amount of delay
eighty percent of the the backlog delays
is caused by people who can't get to see
a consultant or can't get the scan that
they need in time we're trying to fix
that by making scan scanning and
screening more accessible and faster to
speed up the process thank you very much